hello everyone my name is alana and
today i wanted to talk about the
outriders launch
the purpose of this video is to
basically explain
something that i think people
misunderstand about these kinds of
launches
time and time again but to add context
first
outriders is a co-op rpg third-person
shooter gears of war vibes
some destiny vibes in there and it came
out on april 1st
if we pull up the outriders twitter you
can kind of get a very good timeline of
events because frankly
this team has been doing a wonderful job
of trying to keep people up to date so
day one starts with the outrider's
twitter account saying should you
encounter any issues we are continually
tracking and updating our known issues
and workarounds thread here which is
this thread our teams are also working
hard to ensure reported issues are
investigated
and then the reported issues begin we
are seeing some reports of server outage
for some players we're investigating and
we'll update you soon
back online and then we are tracking
reports of player encounters stuttering
micro stuttering on pc and have posted
potential workaround such fixes here uh
this is
an issue that i have had and then again
we're tracking intermittent server
disconnects and are investigating what
is going on please keep an eye on status
dot outrighters.net though we will also
aim to update you
when we have news so this is the tweet
that says please try logging in again
please be patient if it takes a moment
and has a lot of people just talking
about having major connection issues
none of which i doubt um i'm positive
that this is happening but this
particular tweet right here which is
from
sourcelessnight which says well this is
the second time you guys have said the
server problems have been fixed and nope
still happening micro starters are also
insane on pc still
why do companies insist on releasing
games that are not ready in this day
first impressions are usually the only
impression um and this is a pretty
common thing to see around any
server-based game that doesn't work on
launch um there are a whole bunch of
tweets about this
this kind of thing like again still
having server disconnect issues guys
it's 2021 why can we not have a stable
online launch
why have we not learned from other
mistakes in the past why is this still a
thing because it shouldn't be your
company has more than enough money and
resources to figure it out
so i'm not going to tell you that i
disagree with what these people are
saying
i'm not going to tell you that i think
that games should launch
with problems i would much prefer every
video game launched without problems
however because so many of them are
asking questions
while i recognize a lot of these people
just kind of are asking these questions
rhetorically and don't want an answer to
why these things happen in the way that
they do because yeah i get that a lot of
them are just
you know complaining which they
completely have right to do but
in case even one person is asking
these questions genuinely uh i wanted to
make this video to answer
it so that um maybe people would have a
little bit more of an understanding of
why this happens repeatedly
when it seems like most people like why
have we not learned from mistakes why is
this still a thing your company has more
than enough money resources to figure
this thing out
the truth is it's very complicated
shockingly video games are hard to make
but um there is a lot more to it than
that and this is something that i have
spoken to countless developers about
again speaking generally it could be the
case for some but it is generally not
a problem of if we just pay more money
have more room on servers then this
won't be an issue
and instead of just telling you that um
usually for this kind of thing i would
like maybe
do an interview but then i realized that
this article
austin wood on gamesradar from 2019
uh actually does a really good job of
talking about exactly
kind of what i intended to talk about as
a slight aside i remember a game of
telling me this and it just kind of
stuck with me forever uh
people talk about qa like how are their
bugs was this game not qa tested
every game is qa tested it just is a
matter of how many of those bugs get
implemented but also some of them are
not
found and the reason that the public
finds
bugs so easily when qa departments may
not find them or
the studios may not be able to fix them
is because if you think about it this
way
the minute that a game is released to
the public
just even in a day there are
a million more hours pulling numbers out
of the air to paint a picture here
there are a million more hours of play
testing
than the qa team could ever do just the
minute something's public
so many more hours of the game have been
played than have ever been played before
so it's often that the dev team has no
idea what's coming
because you cannot test for things on
this scale no matter how much qa you do
unless you have the budget to pay
millions or hundreds of thousands or
even tens of thousands of people just a
qa test that's just a thing that i like
to think about is like it really puts it
into perspective
uh how limited qa still really is
compared to the general public and why
qa isn't able to just
fix all of those problems also for
anyone who doesn't know the shorthand qa
is quality assurance they are the
department of any game dev studio that
goes through and tries to check
for bugs essentially but back to the
article to talk about why this kind of
thing happens so they have a quote here
from alex mann
a development manager and former qa
analyst at ea
who said one of the mindsets you see
online a lot is why
hasn't company a got more servers and
capacity isn't necessarily about the
number of
servers the way that people think it
might be they then spoke to the director
of live services at massive
entertainment who made the division he
said large online games are extremely
complex pieces of software relying on a
massive online server infrastructure to
support it
on top of that you also have the
additional layer of first party services
so there are a lot of different ways
things can go wrong
but us on the division the main types of
incidents that could cause downtime or
connectivity problems were instability
in the game software running on the
servers which is generally
the issue or hosting provider issues
running out of server capacity is very
rarely the problem
on the division 2 our servers scale
automatically depending on the number of
players wanting to play the game the
article goes on to say any number of
things can go wrong on launch day and
more often than not share play account
is relatively low on the watch lists
um they also have this aside here that i
think is super interesting and it's
something that is definitely a huge
misconception
uh that talks about how
people think development teams operate
um specifically the idea that anyone can
fix anything or even that anyone would
have seen everything
he said when you're dealing with complex
code bases spanning multiple files built
by 200 people if i look at my coders and
they built this
code a doesn't know that entire project
there's this concept that everybody
knows everything about the game code so
the level artist should be helping with
the fix for the level architecture
that's definitely a really common thing
it's like someone yelling at someone who
has nothing to do with something about
the thing
or in a lot of cases um
someone from a dev team will talk about
some facet of something that they made
and they could have absolutely no idea
about a totally separate section of the
game
that's not the way these kind of things
operate not everyone is actively aware
of every single piece of this
giant machine that makes a video game
giant virtual machine but still so if
you're like
asking you know an environment artist
why something didn't load correctly the
amount of people who can actually do
that is way way
way way smaller and you can't use the
whole team and just have everyone work
overtime to try to fix these problems
essentially but yes again
more often than it is server capacity
being full
uh it could be a memory leak a single
but catastrophic line of incorrect code
or a spot of lag buried somewhere
in the enormous server pipeline a game
might have an issue with a certain isp
the first party services or really
anything else the problem could be
anywhere but no matter where it is
it's everybody's problem nobody is in
ireland when it comes to online games
and that can make responding to issues
incredibly difficult and time-consuming
and every launch is different
as they go on to say and complicated um
but essentially this is kind of what i
wanted to say is that you know the
reason that these mistakes keep
happening
is because they don't know how to
anticipate what mistake will happen
unless you can have hundreds of
thousands of people
repeatedly test things for you under the
exact circumstances they should be under
without like ruining your marketing
cycle or harming anything else
it is very difficult to guess what will
go wrong
nobody knows that anything is going to
be wrong upon launch again it's not a
matter of just getting extra service
based most of the time it is a matter of
like
one tiny thing ripple effect breaking a
bunch of stuff and it's not that they
didn't test for this it's just that you
can't
reasonably test for potentially millions
of players there is just no feasible way
to do
that this then continues to talk about
what is this ad what the heck
the article then goes on to talk about
how a lot of the solutions are found and
there is definitely again a kind of
online rhetoric that you can see
sometimes
of people saying why don't you just
press the button and fix it like why
can't you just
fix it um the fixes can take a very long
time that is a matter of
sifting through the issues that are
being reported to figure out what the
problem
actually is and then figuring out
specifically what is causing it what
variable
is causing this exact problem on this
amount of machines
do they have anything in common like how
are they writing their reports
um there are issues with players
generally being pretty bad at qa
it's not their jobs they shouldn't have
to do it um but it does mean that that
is a big part of the hold-up is figuring
out what exactly has
caused the issue and then they have to
figure out a way to fix the issue
and correct the issue which isn't so
much as like type a new line of code or
throw money at it it requires the the
even
smaller group of people who work at the
company who have the skills
to actually understand that piece of
code or that area or that
issue to issue a fix to work on a fix
that won't just break everything else
and that is definitely something that's
really common because code is very
fickle
they have to figure out if it's a patch
if it's something that can be updated on
their side and then they have to test it
extensively before pushing it live which
is just not a process that can be fixed
like that there are also you know
intermittently in that process a bunch
of people who would bottleneck it like
you know you might have to talk to
microsoft or sony um every step of the
way
while updating a game to make sure that
it's running correctly on their service
as well
it's not something that you can just
kind of push in a lot of cases
especially in the
aaa space so that's kind of part of why
sometimes instead of just releasing
quick fixes all the time which probably
would just break the game
would bottleneck things more because
there are too many of them a lot of
studios will try to do like one a day or
one every second day to get as many
issues contained as they can before
pushing the patch which to players means
well hey this thing that i paid 60 for
is taking two days before it works and
i fully understand why that's
frustrating again just trying to explain
for anyone who's genuinely curious about
why this kind of thing happens the way
that it does so then you know getting
through all that paperwork it's a matter
of pushing the fix
and then getting even more effectively
player qa feedback to see if it broke
anything else to see if it worked the
way that it was supposed to
to see if it worked well enough and then
taking that feedback and continuing the
cycle essentially nothing's an easy fix
and the whole studio can't do it it's
not something where they can just throw
money at it more service space doesn't
generally fix these kinds of problems
and yeah every single game is different
um so the challenges are completely
different there is no like well
they were developed on the same engine
like it doesn't even work that way it's
so
unpredictable and i feel like i just
want to say you know working on the
development side of the industry and
having so many friends who work on the
development side of the industry
nobody wants a game to launch this way
they definitely do not want this they
more than anything are hoping when they
hit go live
the big go live button that everyone has
at their game studio
that the game will work for everyone uh
and they want it to work as quickly as
possible
the truth just is that for every device
i've ever spoken to about this
a lot of the issues just cannot be
anticipated um
you can guess that there might be
problems but you will have
absolutely no idea what they are so you
can't prepare for them internal testing
is ultimately limited
and nothing can compare to actually
launching a game there's there's no way
to simulate
the actual proper live experience where
you just don't know what will go wrong
the article i actually went on to talk
to frank sanchez so just let me pull it
back here
to sort of related to what i was just
talking about sanchez said it's just
impossible
there is no substitute i've seen every
method of stress testing something
internally before you put it out there
and there's just no simulation for life
so then they go on to talk about why
developers don't just hold more betas
generally due to time constraints and
limitations
um and generally a game is not ready
to even be played by the public in a
beta phase and you don't want to turn
people off your game by having a bad
beta because it does honestly concern
people but i'll leave a link to the
article because this is really
comprehensive it covers a lot of the the
stuff that i you know when i was like oh
i should make this video i found this
article and i was like oh it covers
pretty much
all of the stuff i was going to say but
yes i want to be clear that i don't
think that any
uh consumer anyone who bought a game
that they can't play day one
is in the wrong by complaining about it
by any means or by asking for a refund
you should totally do that
um that's a thing i am very pro
is getting refunds for things if you
aren't happy with the product
and i'm not trying to excuse these
issues i would also certainly prefer
that every game
launched without any problems whatsoever
and i'm sure every studio would prefer
that too
i just wanted to make this video for the
people who are genuinely asking the
question of how does this stuff keep
happening
why haven't they fixed this why they
launched a broken game and the answer is
ultimately that they don't know it's
broken
until they launch it and there's not
really any way to test for it
maybe someone will figure out a solution
in the future
but i promise you no one's taking
shortcuts right now this isn't
even uh in a lot of the cases of online
games a like the game is rushed for
money
situation that certainly does happen
when your stockholders get too involved
in development but in the case of
something like outright as it doesn't
feel that way to me
this just feels like a regular old video
game being a regular old video game
which means that what can go wrong will
go wrong and they won't know what that
is
until the game is live so yeah again to
those who are genuinely interested
i hope this uh answers some of those
questions if you are asking them
rhetorically
just i apologize feel free to send them
tweets that is it for me today everyone
i'll see you guys next time
bye